the dog ate everybody Sean McGuinness
here at PAX East alongside Hunter Howe
who is the creative director of don gate
the game we're about to check out right
now hunter how you doing I'm doing great
I'm doing great really exciting be it
packs yeah it's a lot of fun so Don gate
it is a new entry into the MOBA genre
obviously a very competitive space there
are some heavy hitters in in the world
of MOBAs what are you guys trying to do
to set yourself apart we've got a lot of
differences a lot of things that we're
trying to do in game play you know while
a lot of MOBAs might look similar
because the isometric camera you know we
really wanted to do a lot of different
things gameplay wise so not the least of
which is really you're gonna see right
here a two lane map with four economy
nodes on the map so the gameplay is
really revolves around these objectives
similar to some of the other MOBAs we we
have a defensive structure that you need
to destroy to win the game ours is like
a big MMO style raid boss who like
shoots down all of these a ohi's and
it's really sort of a PvE element that's
meant to create awesome teamfight at the
end of the game but the two lands with
five players create a lot of interesting
flexible options for players to build
comps around so we have something called
the roll system what you see right now
with this this guy playing dibs is that
he's a tactician so he's gonna scale
really well into the game by doing what
tactician x' do best which is hanging
out in a lane helping people and
harassing a lot and so the more he can
land his abilities the more vim our
currency he's gonna get his friend
there's a gladiator who's focusing on
last-hitting you can do a number of
different things like you can run a two
tactician Lane you can run a trial and
the role system allows everybody to
scale and and build comps to to be able
to create diverse strategies where you
get things like double jungle try lanes
and this is sort of a more traditional
thing that you'll see in our game that
people can
break in a lot of ways oh we actually
have like a trial and with a with a
Roman ganker right now that's somebody
using the predator role so it's really
flexible in terms of how you want to
play the game let's talk about your map
layout here is it is it one map that you
guys are focusing on is it multiple maps
what's the situation there we're focused
100% on making the dawn gate with the
map is the dawn gate as as fun as
possible you know we don't want to we
don't want to sort of dilute our dev
resources into something else because
like we really believe that you know the
the MOBA game play you know the map
needs to stand up to thousands of hours
of gameplay it needs to have that depth
and it needs to have that balance so
we're 100% dedicated to this map right
now let's talk about the layout then
obviously it's a little bit different
from your kind of standard just square
shape you guys you know there are those
bases in either corner but the layout
layouts a bit different from what people
you know a dota or League expert would
kind of expect
yeah people people who jump in from
those games like we have a lot of great
beta players that have come from those
games and they they'll feed a bunch at
first because they'll expect them have
to be map to be similar but as you see
it's got those two lanes they're
relatively close together something that
we really wanted was a lot of those like
mid game skirmishes I think are like
some of the most fun parts of MOBA
gameplay when you get like those 2v2 3v3
ganks people coming to reinforce other
lanes so those two lanes are relatively
close together allowing people to
reinforce back and forth oh this is an
incredible towerdive happening right now
so also you know those those four
objectives George could you pan over to
a spirit well for me so these are our
economy nodes that are in the map and so
two teams start with two of those and
they can be captured by the enemy team
and they can be cleared out of their
workers which the team uses to generate
passive to
income so so really you know we we were
thinking a lot about the roots of the
genre of MOBA and thinking like what are
actually some of those things were
interesting in the RTS is that this was
born from that we can pull back in and
we really thought the idea of like bases
and ticking economy and somebody coming
in and like using a ohi's and clearing
out a bunch of workers that's like a
really exciting spectator moment and you
know the genre so so about those those
spectator moments where people can watch
and you know the success of eSports is
really testament to that so we sort of
wanted that that emotional sort of high
for the for the viewer but also all that
again PvE that reinforces PvP so you see
a lot more early game action as opposed
to passive farming which I'm really
happy about it dawn gate so you see
we're getting right into the sort of
Guardian fight towards the towards the
end of the match if things continue to
go well for these guys so the Guardian
is in the center and he's got these
cores around him and the cores are
destructible structures that you have to
destroy all of them to make the guard
again vulnerable to damage at all and
they all each individually give the
Guardian a really impactful ability so
you can take down one core and that'll
be like oh good we got rid of his
ability to make that giant line of fire
and like oh let's get this other one
that that'll stop the AOE fire pool that
their their team is really good at
locking us into oh that's interesting so
it's not just you knock down that thing
and there goes 20% of his armor it's an
actual tangible ability yeah I know he
like will shoot this laser beam that'll
create a pool of fire that'll do like a
third of your health bar per tick right
so it's extremely strong but you can
dodge it yeah we wanted all of his
abilities to be skill shots not targeted
to allow players to outplay the Guardian
if they were alone and close out the
game but if the enemy team is there
playing with those abilities really
successfully like armor like shield
bashing somebody into a fire line and
then there
trapped and they're separated from their
team that that would create a lot of
really interesting plays so it's it's
much more it's much more fun than
destroying a structure there's like
there is that sort of like Boston
counter feel to it yeah that's really
interesting because I'd imagine that
depending on the makeup of the team
you'd try to focus on different
approaches try to take out different
abilities first before the others yeah
we went back and forth on the design
there because there was there's a burden
of knowledge on a communication that we
have to give people like that's what
that does that's what that does that was
what that does but we feet and we could
have just said oh it just gets rid of an
ability every time and this one is
always the last one to go but we wanted
that extra you know team comp specific I
play around it because that's just it's
more strategic depth and to my point
before it doesn't add that much
complication to it it's still relatively
clear there's a fire ball over one of
those cores get that one you know stop
doing fire balls pretty straightforward
I guess we you know we talked a little
bit about the metagame stuff but while
we go ahead and circle back and talk
about that a little bit more I mean how
you talked about you wanted to keep it
flexible what do you mean by that I mean
that I want you to be able to bring to
strategize around a variety of comps I
want you to be able to play the
character you want more often like
something that I that I would not want
in the game is like you really like love
and are invested in a particular
character you've been practicing that
character you get into Schafer select
and then somebody locks one character
and they're like well you can't be that
guy now and it's like that really that
really stinks you know if there's a
character that you love so the ability
for characters to fill in multiple roles
and be like okay I I wanted to play a
really aggressive character to I can do
that I'm just gonna do that as a support
you know as a tactician and that will
allow me to scale just as well as you
trying to be this really killer oriented
person or we we actually have the
ability that you could run two
technicians in a lion we have the
ability that's like somebody say I want
a solo Elaine you're like okay we'll run
a tri lane bottom
so just a lot of configurations still
allowing you to play the characters that
you really like just in the roles that
are helpful for your team and and to
explore you know a lot of interesting
comms so as we come to the conclusion of
the match here let's talk about the
status of the beta when you guys plan
into you know fully release the game
when is that gonna happen do you have
any sort of timeline in mind right now
we've not set a timetable for for the
later stages of our beta just because we
we're gonna spend the time to fix those
those things I told you about like we
really want to deliver on the promises
that we're we're setting up those things
that I just said in the interview like I
want them to be absolutely 100% true you
know I want a really flexible meta so
we're just continuing to iterate in beta
so we're in community beta right now
which does mean that you don't need a
key to get in you just go to Don get
calm and grab it we want to we want to
just keep making the game better before
it's out there for launch cool well
thanks a lot for your time no problem
thank you